We all have some concerns when it comes to money.
So I thought, why do not we use technology to help?
Money Forward allows you to manage your financial information
From bank accounts to credit cards, bonds and loyalty points,
All through one application.
You can check everything right away at a glance at your smartphone,
Such as checking your income, expenses, current balance, and the like.
All of this data is updated in real time.
We asked about Google's multidimensional design after it was announced,
It was helpful to us.
In the first month we achieved a 30% increase in total users,
And 7% retention rate
We faced a 4% drop in the bounce rate.
Using user interface models on display,
We were able to create a great user interface for our product.
We've found that tablet users are more likely to pay for
In-app purchases more than 1.5 times the number of smartphone users.
While it is likely to drive both smartphone and tablet users
Almost tripled.
Before using 3D design,
We should have allocated a lot of time whenever there was an update to the operating system.
Now, however, the Android Support Library ensures that even after the operating system is updated,
The app will work the same way. It is a real provider of time.
A good example of how to help us is CoordinatorLayout.
There was one case where we developed an advantage
Automatically hide the title when you scroll down a page.
But this feature stopped working after upgrading the operating system.
Fortunately, the Support Library now provides this type of functionality.
Our Android Wear app will be compatible soon.
You can now add to your account book using voice recognition.
Also think about adding a feature to send a notice to users
About incoming city balances.
For example, "Payment on Monday" or "Your credit is not enough."
As our service addresses sensitive customer information,
We are very attentive to safety.
This means applying strict security measures at every step
From processing device data to encrypting transfers.
Google provides us with the ideal platform
To explore new technology and create great applications
Hopefully it will have a positive impact on the lives of many people.